STRAIGHT.
BIG PLAYERS ARE HOT AND THE NEW
GUYS ARE SETTLING IN.
A CHECK THEIR BY COLTON THEY HA
THE RUSH.
THIS IS A MISTAKE.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
AND I KNOW JOHN COOPER TALKEDAN
WENT OFF.
IT IS IN THE THIS ONE STAYS IN.
PAST THE MIDWAY POINT AND SHOT
HE CENTERS IT OUT. THEY HAVE BE
95% IN IS KNOWN FOR IT AND
ALL PENSIVELY HE USES IT AS
WELL.
GETTING FEED.
>> ANTHONY WALKS IT OFF. BRINGS
FEET.
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
THAT ONE GOES HIGH.
>> THIS YOU WILL
SEE THIS A LOT.
ONE TEAM MISSES AT ONE END AND
THE OTHER TEAM COMES BACK AND
SCORES ON THUP BY
THE BACK-ED BACK ACROSS TO CIRC
CHECK.IT HIT THE NEAR POST.
WHEN THE FORWARD IS ON THE
MOVE, HE HAS AN ADVANTAGE OVER
UP THE MIDDLE HE COMES, THEN
WHEN YOU ARE GOALSCORER YOU GET
SOME GOOD LUCK.
SEASON PLAYOFF RUN.
>> Brian: THAT PLAY STARTED ON
INE LIGHTNING ARE TIED
UP IN KNOTS INSIDE.
CASHING IN BUT THE LIGHTNING
GETTING LEANED ON.
THE SHOT IS BLOCKED ANHANGS ON.